[Musique]
la réunion département français à une
très grande chance de pouvoir accueillir
ses chefs-d'oeuvre venus du musée du
louvre
ici cinq musées sont labellisés et parmi
ces 5 3 sont des musées départementaux
c'est une grande richesse pour notre
territoire de pouvoir disposer de ces
espaces culturels mais c'est aussi une
grande chance pour nous de pouvoir
accueillir c'est celle de m c'est pour
cela que j'invite chaque citoyen
réunionnais à aller vers nos musées à
pouvoir admirer ces d'oeuvre qui quitte
jamais le louvre et nous avons cette
chance de pouvoir les accueillir ici
alors il faut quand même en profiter
pour aller faire ses visites mais c'est
aussi je le dirai en cette période de
crise sanitaire l'occasion de s'évader
un peu de sortir de notre quotidien fait
de difficulté de pouvoir en admirant ces
chefs-d'oeuvre eh bien nous imprégner de
cette part de rêve qui doit animer notre
personnalité donc allons vers les musées
départementaux les musées régionaux
allons la découverte de ces
chefs-d'oeuvre venus du musée du louvre
à travers résonance
il ya trois ans il ya eu un premier
voyage de préparation de façon à
rencontrer les collègues et me permettre
d'appréhender quels étaient les
collections dont il avait la
responsabilité
et avec chacun donc d'entre eux de
déterminer comment nous pouvions établir
ce dialogue entre leurs collections et
la collection du musée du louvre alors
il ya plus de 239 qui vont venir à la
réunion à l'été 2020 avec la volonté de
ce dialogue entre les collections du
musée du louvre et les collections du
musée rayonner donc par exemple au
muséum d'histoire naturelle il s'agit
d'un ensemble réalisé par un peintre
flamand qui travaillé pour louis xiv est
notamment qui a dessiné la ménagerie de
louis xiv à versailles dont des animaux
exotiques
donc ce sont des très belles planches
coloré animaux exotiques tels qu'ils
étaient connus au xviie siècle ici donc
à villèle qu'il s'agira de montrer donc
les lieux emblématiques de paris au
xviiie siècle puisque le propriétaire de
cette maison est venu en 1984 1986 à
paris donc autour d'oeuvres de bouche et
enfin de peintres célèbres de 7,2 ce
temps 1 et puis allez on dire si on a
fait un choix avec notre collègue de
d'oeuvre importante d'un gros de
chassériau de delacroix ou les grands
artistes français du 19e siècle mais je
crois que ce qui paraît important c'est
de se dire que c'est l'occasion ou
jamais de redire combien il est
important par les temps qui courent
donner encore et encore et toujours tout
ça passe et la culture c'est facile et
dessinent ou facile à faire surtout s'il
s'agit de musées ont plus facilement ce
qu'il faut ce week end dont la structure
n'a pas quatre demain un colloque sur le
mur
sur toussaint louverture à saint-andré
mais on a plus de mal à venir dans un
musée quel qu'il soit sur du papyrus qui
sinon partout et
nous osons espérer effectivement
président melchior dignement qui lance
en 18 ans au 1110 que cet apport cette
présence du loup ici être l'occasion de
rahmouni est encore et toujours plus de
monde à nos musiques évidemment pour la
la réunion c'est une chance
extraordinaire mais c'est une chance
aussi de faire dialoguer c'est épique
qui viennent du grand musée national
avec des oeuvres qui sont conservés à la
réunion dans dans les musées dans les
musées de la réunion et singulièrement
dans les musées des parents
voilà c'est chose faite et bien c'est
fait nous sommes mariés
et à merci
[Musique]
cette opération a mobilisé des moyens
considérables
on a travaillé en partenariat avec le
musée du loup bien entendu mais
également les services de l'état est
également donc tous les services du
département sont pleinement mobilisés
pour cette opération ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que il faut 48 heures
d'acclimatation pour que
entre le moment où les oeuvres arrive à
la réunion et les réserves on puisse
être déballés donc ils sont ils seront
conservées dans les musées dans les
conditions de sécurité est optimale mais
également en respectant les normes de
conservation qui nous ont été clairement
imposé par le louvre mais que pour
lequel nous mêmes les nos musées on
respecte en général
donc on va se diriger vers la salle
des expositions temporaires du musée où
seront accrochées les oeuvres du musée
du loup qui arrive aujourd'hui
de métropole ce qu'on peut voir derrière
moi ou accrocher un peu partout sur le
mur on a mis en fait des du craft
donc ce sont toutes les oeuvres qui vont
exposer et les crafton aux dimensions
des cadres c'est l'ordre de présentation
des oeuvres à l'intérieur de la salle
là c'est la partie technique on voit
mais le gros enjeu sait maintenant
comment inciter le public à venir
comment lui expliquer les choix qui ont
été faits comment lui montrer les
oeuvres comment lui expliquer déjà parce
que une fois de plus cette exposition
elle est faite pour que le public la
regarde et notre métier maintenant c'est
de faire de la médiation pour que on
puisse comprendre ce tel ou tel dessin
c'est des dessins certes mais avec des
noms très connus et très célèbre dans
l'histoire de l'art durant la première
moitié du xixème siècle avec bernard
leveneur donc nous avons souhaité que
les oeuvres du musée des ondes hier ce
vieil prêt à prendre place dans le
parcours de l'exposition pour mettre en
parallèle et bien par exemple un paysage
par patu de rosemont avec un paysage par
eugène isabey et voir si effectivement
ces règles établies par l'académie et
bien s'appliquer aussi à la production à
la réunion et c'est tout ce que nous
souhaitons démontrer donc au sein de
l'exposition du musée léon dierx
c'était émouvant parce que c'est deux
ans et demi de travail
voilà donc la
le public pourra voir à la fois les
dessins d'un par exemple d'un perroquet
d'un art un ara rauna il verra l'animal
naturalisé en bas il pourra voir
également une antilope
et nous avons deux ou trois antilopes
qui sont exposés au rez-de-chaussée
voilà donc on a voulu cette résonance
entre les collections les objets du
muséum et ses oeuvres de peter brook
unes à unes on va les regarder et on va
voir s'il ya des changements par rapport
au départ de paris donc on a un document
contractuel
qui décrit le dessin
est donc c'est ce document que gaël
s'engagent à signer et si jamais une
modification a lieu au l'emprisonnent
immédiatement que
c'est un peu comme quand on récite une
voiture location exact
donc encadrement miro gare donc départ
du musée du louvre rien à signaler le 27
mai arrivé à saint denis
déballage le 4 juin
observations sur l'évolution des tas de
l'oeuvre rien n'a signalé
noé signature du convoyeur dont je signe
et qu'at elle signe à son tour et donc
nous sommes d'accord sur l'état du
dessin
et vous allez répéter cette procédure en
chaque heure pour chaque oeuvre ayant
été prêté à la réunion donc ici 29
dessin en tout 230 six dessins dans les
cinq différents musées la réunion au
moment du décrochage de l'exposition on
regardera de nouveau les oeuvres et on
verra s'il ya un changement ou pas tous
leur constaté à l'arrivée et ont leur
constate à l'arrivée ensuite donc à
quatre fois la même opération pour être
sûr que les oeuvres n'ont pas évolué
c'est une opération exceptionnelle qu'on
ne verra à réunion peut-être qu'une fois
c'est le louvre qui se déplace à réunion
et nous avons une collection de peter
bol sur les animaux sur la faune et sur
la flore qui est magnifique et qui est
en résonance avec toutes les collections
que nous avons dans ce musée
je pense que péter mollez l'un des plus
grands peintres animaliers qui soir avec
des oeuvres vraiment exceptionnel et il
a il n'a pas c'est pas l'animal dans son
entier qui l'intéressent lui ce qu'il a
voulu capter ces les animaux sur le vif
des expressions des attitudes des
comportements et du coup ça donne des
oeuvres extrêmement vivante un regard
sur la nature qui est absolument
exceptionnelle nous avons voulu créer
quelque chose d'un petit peu plus
originale en faisant appel à l'artiste
lionel laurède pour cette immersion en
fait ces originaux sont des esquisses
qui vont servir à dieter bull a créé les
tableaux dont s'est inspiré lionel
lorette et ses tableaux vos vont servir
policiers de la meuf manufacture des
gobelins pour créer les tapisseries des
maisons royales qui sont les tapisseries
un peu à la gloire de louis xiv c'est
une exposition tout à fait
exceptionnelle avec des hors
exceptionnels
[Musique]
la danse dans cet espace du muséum qui
est censé accueillir les oeuvres moi mon
travail c'était de faire un travail
d'animation mais pas trop ardue assez
légères qui permet de rentrer un petit
peu dans les oeuvres de façon un peu
immersive donc l'idée c'était qu'on voit
quand même les oeuvres donc en fait on
n'est pas parti dans du walt disney qui
bouge dans tous les sens j'ai fait un
travail mois de détourage plutôt donc 2
des tableaux qui sont des tableaux
préparatoire en fait à une tapisserie
finale et l'idée c'était d'être un peu
immergé à l'origine en entrant dans la
pièce qui accueille les oeuvres alors en
fait fondamentalement ce qui est
intéressant avec ce genre de dispositif
c'est que
ça nous permet une sorte d' aspect
ludique en fait d'entrer dans l'image et
d'intéresser le plus grand nombre donc
du coup à travers ces images qui sont un
petit peu c'est un petit peu magique
parce que c'est un petit peu grand comme
ça du coup on fait ça sensibilise et du
coup les gens ensuite peuvent aller
découvrir les oeuvres qui se trouve
derrière l'écran ce que nous souhaitons
c'est que le public réunionnais bien
reprennent ou prenne ce chemin des cinq
musées de la réunion pour pouvoir
découvrir différents aspects à la fois
des collections de l'île de la réunion
parce que c'est une un moyen de se
réapproprier les collections des musées
l'île de la réunion tout en découvrant
un aspect des collections du musée du
loup c'est une première effectivement le
pour la première fois le louvre
prête un nombre extrêmement important
d'oeuvres de ses collections il ya déjà
eu des préfets à la réunion en
particulier pour des expositions qui
avait été organisée au manoir
mais cette aide le quelques oeuvres dans
le cadre d'un propos donc
porté par le musée dumas de loi là pour
la première fois effectivement ce sont
cinq expositions entièrement créés pour
la réunion est justement en résonance
avec les collections des musées de l'île
les expositions normalement devrait
ouvrir au public dans la semaine du 22
juin
et elles fermeront le 15 octobre donc il
ya presque quatre mois d'exposition pour
pouvoir bien circuler de vilaine à léon
dierx
de léon dierx assez là bas tout tina de
stella matutina à la villa dumas doit à
saint-denis et ainsi découvrir donc
l'ensemble de ses oeuvres
exceptionnellement prêtés à l'arrivée
c'est la première fois qu'on travaille
avec le musée du louvre le musée du
louvre a choisi la réunion a choisi les
musées du des parents et les musées de
la région parce que il l'a reconnu la
qualité des collections la qualité des
dieux et la qualité du travail qui est
fait dans les différentes équipes de ces
différents musées c'est aussi une
opportunité pour les réunionnais de
découvrir des dessins de découvrir en
fait la première étape de la création
artistique c'est vrai que et à la
peinture et à la sculpture mais très
souvent artistes tous les artistes
passent même encore aujourd'hui il passe
par une phase de dessins qu'il y ait la
traduction de la première idée sur une
feuille de papier et pose qui concerne
le musée léon dierx on a dans
l'exposition de très grands noms de la
peinture et du dessin en fait des très
grands artistes du bien c'est qu'on a
par exemple un dessin d'ingres qui est
le dessin d'un portrait très connu de
dingue on a deux dessins de jéricho un
dessin de la croix et c'est vraiment la
façon d'aborder l'art à travers le
dessin et de découvrir finalement la
première étape le premier processus dans
l'étape de création et dans la
réalisation d'un tableau mais aussi le
dessin a été un genre autonome
c'est-à-dire que certaines oeuvres qui
sont exposés dans cette salle comme par
exemple visuel de l'exposition qui est
derrière moi et qui est le dessin d'un
artiste français qui est allé au brésil
qui s'appelle le compte de clarac et qui
a fait cette forêt brésilienne en
cumulant différents détails de deux feux
de forêt qu'ils avaient pu observer sur
place est une oeuvre autonome
c'est-à-dire que ce dessin n'est pas la
préparation d'une peinture c'est une
oeuvre à part entière qui n'existe qu'un
exemplaire unique et qui se trouve
aujourd'hui dans les salles du musée non
de telles mauvaises surprises ça va
non ça va parfois quelques ondulations
mais ça va plutôt plutôt bien le fait
que de la destination soit tropicale
enfin génère des précautions
supplémentaires oui oui oui quasiment
tous les dessins qui ont été envoyés ici
sauf au musée léon dierx
l'ont été sous cadre dit climatique qui
présente des qualités d'absorption
bien supérieure à ce que l'on fait
ordinairement et ce qui nous permet un
peu plus de confort une interface
supplémentaires entre entre le dessin et
son environnement beaucoup de ces
dessins n'ont pas de valeur sur le
marché parce que leur valeur est
simplement trop haute il n'y a pas
d'équivalent parfois pour les dessins
des collections du musée du louvre
et on est bien en peine
de donner cette valeur d'assurance aux
compagnies d'assurance il ya un mois le
faire parce qu il faut bien ta blessure
un montant d'indemnités possible si
jamais il est maire mais il ya des
dessins extrêmement important oui
le portrait de monsieur bertin parrain
le dessin préparatoire et un dessin sans
équivalent pour une des oeuvres les plus
importantes un des portraits les plus
célèbres d'ingres donc oui il ya des
choses de très grande valeur déjà voir
du dessin est une chose rare que l'on
soit à la réunion que l'on soit ailleurs
dans le monde c'est quand même un objet
d'une immense fragilité parce qu'une
feuille de papier c'est presque rien
nous présente dans toutes ses
expressions défaite très importante qui
ne vont plus être présentés de fait
après pendant cinq années parce que la
règle pour un dessin et qu'il est
présenté quatre mois puis mis au noir
pendant un symbole
c'est l'occasion ou jamais
après les réunionnais plus personne ne
les verra pendant cinq ans c'est peu de
chose et pour des desseins aussi
important plus retraite monsieur bertin
c'est un vrai choix de le présenter ici
plutôt qu'ailleurs ces délais sont très
demandés il est d'ores et déjà sorti de
son emballage il est là derrière vous et
c'est le deuxième dé s'imposer au sol
[Musique]
cette exposition était une incroyable
opportunité
pour présenter une sélection d'oeuvres
du musée du louvre en particulier des
dessins et des gravures qui proviennent
de cette grande institution et qui donne
à voir des vues de paris de monuments de
scènes de vie
deux morceaux d'architecturé qui ont été
découverts par henri paul un panneau
desbassyns ce créole de bourbon qui
découvrent pour la première fois le pays
de france au xviiie siècle il se trouve
que lorsqu'en ripolin fait ce grand
voyage il a été très impressionné par ce
qu'il a découvert là-bas et il a pris
des notes il a pris des notes qui ont
fait l'objet d'un travail d'archiviste
qui ont été retranscrites et qui ont été
éditées par le par le musée
dans la première salle de cette académie
il y avait un bel homme tout nu sur une
table il était dans une attitude gênante
tout autour étaient les pinces qui
dessinaient chacun leurs morceaux il
était assis sur des gradins pour que
ceux qui étaient derrière puisse voir il
y avait des personnes qui faisaient des
modèles en terre tout se passe dans le
plus grand silence c'était intéressant
effectivement de présenter ses oeuvres
par rapport aux témoignages
henri paul un pan dans des bassins et là
on a effectivement une démonstration
effectivement de ce qui se passe au
niveau artistique les les personnages
qui sont représentés présente une
une fluidité dans le geste on peut le
voir de façon très très net et pour
donner un petit peu plus de relief au
corps aux représentations corporelle le
l'artiste a utilisé la craie blanche qui
permet de créer ce relief et de et de
contrastes le papier qui est utilisée si
on regarde de près il a un grain un
grain permettant la croche de la matière
et ça aussi c'est intéressant de le voir
et de le voir de près c'est ce qui est
aussi l'intérêt de cette exposition
c'est que le visiteur pourra vraiment
regarder de près d'avoir une lecture
très détaillée de ce que les oeuvres
présentes
dans le cadre de cette exposition
je crois qu'on peut parler véritablement
d'un privilège car c'est la première
fois effectivement qu'on présente des
oeuvres du louvre d'un département
d'outre-mer donc on a ce privilège
pendant un temps limité de 4 mois c'est
une exposition temporaire de permettre
aux réunionnaises et réunionnais
effectivement d'approcher des oeuvres
d'ailleurs qui ne pourrait peut-être pas
découvrir à paris parce que ses hommes
ne sont pas présentés de façon
permanente
[Musique]